peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un bon jour et bonsoir bonjour bonsoir
plus exactement parce que nous vous
souhaitons bien au frais chez vous pour
assister à ce troisième intéressante
elle est pour ce soir parce que en
compagnie de l'équipe d'alexis tavillons
vous venez de faire votre entrée dans
les arènes d'alès mais si vous monsieur
merci mme drolet en tête dans les arènes
d'alès par une chaleur étouffante
dans les faits il fait aujourd'hui très
bon mais il fait très très chaud à alès
et il y à une foule d'hommes
probablement 15000 personnes avec ceux
qui ne sont pas plus qu'ils n'ont pas pu
rentrer et d'ailleurs nous laisser l'eau
tout ce qu'ils verront cette édition aux
alentours des varennes grâce à des
récepteurs et à l'intérieur pas loin de
dix mille personnes c'est vous dire que
par plus de 37 à 38 degrés à l'ombre
dirais que ma musique j'avais toujours
dit qu'on n'était pas obligée de se
mettre à l'ombre mais comme il n'y a que
du soleil alors dans les arènes d'alès
et par près de 50 degrés que ces
quelques 10000 personnes vont encourager
notre troisième intervilles qu'ils ont
raison de cette température s'annonce
indiscutablement comme le plus chaud de
toute la série 73 et malgré ces
températures il faudra bien
les concurrents perdent quelques kilos
pour gagner quelques points
en effet les points sont très chers
maintenant regarder ce tableau ce
tableau nous rappelle que c'est un mec
qui a battu la ville de saint gaudens je
dis regardez ce tableau mais bien par
mes visites en termes il faut toujours
être patient qui a battu la ville de
saint gaudens par 15.7 et ensuite evian
deuxième ville qualifiées qui a battu
celle des xvi battre par dix poids à
vide ce qui revient à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut que l'une des
deux équipes de l'est d'avignon face au
moins 10 points et de préférence aux
désastres et merveilleux qu'ils fassent
15 pour action s'est retrouvée le 22
sept ans pour cette fameuse finale
d'intervilles
alors quel est le moral des dirigeants
quelques minutes avant le coup d'envoi
simone garnier naturellement se trouve
encore panier messieurs les maires et de
l'europe d'antan six mois exactement
j'ai à mes côtés monsieur rogero comptes
qui est député maire d'alès et monsieur
millions ti qui on présente ici le
député-maire d'avignon monsieur du faux
eh bien monsieur le maire comme guy
vient de nous le dire
on connaissait la capitale des cévennes
comme aussi capitale des houillères de
ses veines comme centre de l'industrie
du ver à soie il ya déjà quelques
lustres mais on ne savait pas que
pendant les vacances vous étiez la ville
la rue choc de france et aussi il faut
bien le dire la ville
plus joyeuse à ce qui concerne la
chaleur vous vous rendez compte
aujourd'hui qu'effectivement nous sommes
une ville très chaude et en ce qui
concerne à ce qu'il fasse air de la
ville de soyeuses la ville qui sait se
distraire et bien vous vous rendez
compte pas cette immense assistance
calais on sait vivre et on sait s'amuser
est-ce que vous portez cognac est que
l'on a faits au noble le représentant de
la cité des papes
on ne peut plus on ne peut pas dire que
la taille que nous avons eues à l'ess ne
soit pas chaleureux dans toute
l'acception du terme
de toute façon la tate général nous a
plu nous commençons à avoir des liens
d'amitié avec les représentants de la
visibilité thales ainsi qu'avec les
joueurs
toutefois nous sommes quand même pas
venu pour père voilà je crois que ça va
être torride cette interview a laissé
vide mans et je parle pas seulement de
la température
messieurs vous avez prévu des petits
cadeaux alors très très vite je crois
que mettre du sable voilà par monsieur
le maire remet une lampe de mineur à la
municipalité avignonnaise laquelle
laquelle a apporté une ravissante petite
cloche
voilà du palais des papes 1 une copie du
palais des papes la cloche de 13 152 et
l'enregistrement de l'histoire du pont
d'avignon un enregistrement du à
l'initiative de trois journalistes
avignonnais et c'est un enregistrement
de gérant philippe voilà eh bien écoutez
monsieur vous êtes très amis il
n'empêche qu'une toute dernière question
avant que guy nous propose ces jeux
quels sont justement les problèmes que
pose la circulation actuellement
monsieur rockot à alès la circulation à
l'aise et évidemment comme dans beaucoup
de villes
elle est parfois c'est difficile
cependant je dois dire que nous avons
j'ai un avantage sur d'autres vivent ces
tonneaux disposant d'un nombre assez
important de parking ce qui nous permet
de recevoir beaucoup de gens de
l'extérieur dans notre ville
et aujourd'hui je suis persuadé qu'il y
en a un certaine nombre
bonjour le cv en vertu des des très
modestes pouvoirs qui me sont conférés
étant donnée la tenue que nous avons
revêtissent taxe exceptionnelle je vous
autorise à retirer votre reste est tout
de suite et bien en effet comme vient de
l'indiquer notre sympathique simone la
circulation la circulation est bien là
elle va se présenter sous la forme du
premier jeu intitulé franchissement de
la ligne jaune et plus exactement sous
la forme d'un tir à la corde
or vous avez vu que cette année et
chacun de tir à la corde était
particulier celui là va l'être encore
plus que les autres regardez regardez la
reine deux équipes de huit tireurs et au
milieu sur une porte
cette inscription que nous devons
d'ailleurs l'émission d'eurobonds ami
roger pierre et jean marc thibault de
rim qui est derrière la porte au dos
vous dire tout de suite que derrière
cette porte
il y à dolores une merveilleuse vaches
camarguaise car aujourd'hui ce ne sont
pas les landaises américain marc guez et
vous avez compris ceux qui attendent au
tireur
c'est l'équipe qui va franchir la ligne
jaune c'est à dire qui va être tirée
happé par ses adversaires qui va se voir
la porte s'ouvrir sous le nez et la
barbe de ses concurrents ekin avoir de
la grèce sortir en amour l'équipe des
tarifs
sera-ce elle est à la fois ouvrira la
porte et libérer un de leurs ex
attention le jeu n'est pas limitée dans
le temps mais par contre j'ai
l'impression qu'il sera limité dans le
temps dès que de le ressortir à premier
tir à la corde de points sont en jeu
c'est parti et côté immédiatement
arrivent de toute la france l'ambiance
qui va se déchaîner au moment de nos
tops à sept premiers doigts top c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
thibault a dénoncé
lee
ls n'a fait qu'une bouchée de l'équipe
riner se trouve maintenant reprise sous
la forme de 740 kg qui n'a pas pu se
déplacer attendait cet oubli salle et le
restaurant les gens n'allaient sont
heureux ils font face à la tâche
il faut dire que lorsque la vache porte
quelque chose comme 150 à 200 kg de
citadins de des joueurs de l'ess est
bien gardé un nom d'un chef qu'ils sont
bien nourris dans ces deux villes
beaucoup mieux que nous à canards et
bien nous allons à l'essai de leur est
demandé un petit peu à la recherche des
derniers jeux dans ses appartements et
nous allons rentrer
un jeu
djimon depuis fort longtemps il allait
de 3 8 secondes et nos sympathiques
genre d'alès qui faisait à le sol la
bagatelle de 576 kilos et bien auront
perdu que quelques rares regardant le
tableau marquage qui indique déjà deux
pour alès et 0 pour avignon et simone et
bien sinon les enchaînements tout de
suite sur cette circulation difficiles
avec la circulation dans l'arizona
la circulation far west vous avez vu
deux jolies filles qui étaient assis sur
la bétaillère
eh bien nous allons les retrouver cette
moiselle car en 1973 les femmes ne
manque pas de sang froid
non seulement elles sont dans l'arène
mais elles vont y rester enfin avant d'y
rester jusqu'à ce qu'on les délivre oui
n'en déplaise au mlf pour être libéré
les femmes ont encore besoin des hommes
vous êtes bien d'accord messieurs nous
allons avoir deux cavaliers de zorro 2
nuls 2 euros sur des montures un peu
bizarroïdes qui vont prendre le départ
qu'ils vont gagner le centre de l'arène
qui vont devoir enlever ces demoiselles
sous les naseaux de la vache la protéger
du mieux qu'ils pourront comme ils
pourront la ramener et revenir chercher
leurs montures
eh bien naturellement c'est l'équipe qui
aura fait ce chevaleresque exploit le
plus rapidement qui l'emportera
alors attention messieurs les oraux vous
êtes prêts on va donner le top départ
quand la vache sera sorti ce ne sera
plus de leur s ce sera une autre vache
camarguais
c'est vous savez on a beaucoup de
ressources et intervilles ça va être
comme chip chip 3 2 1 partez messieurs
et pour l'instant on bascule tandis que
naturellement d
au centre de la
m
impressionné tandis que les cavaliers et
de raisonner comme
nous
sont durement plus aux puces dimanche en
mêlée
[Applaudissements]
allez
show elle avec s'agit blaise yeux te
descendent que votre fougue boursiers en
europe de lavage qui est prise
mon sens assez de manger et ce moment
[Applaudissements]
oui
quelques semaines je ne sais pas si
facile attention aux documents d'alès la
demoiselle est hors de danger
la demoiselle d'avignon aussi les
demoiselles d'avignon maintenant rentrer
dans ce genre de situation car il faut
dire que ces deux cavaliers
le cheval
la chaîne
[Applaudissements]
mais fort
comité
[Applaudissements]
il faut un peu de tout et de tous
kabangu on va le corps
notre dieu
quand je gagne
vous voyez
tendu
l'outil
nous
merci monsieur tony tomassi fait et
allez
alors on peut dire d'une petite fête une
petite tête
alès effectivement est arrivé un museau
me dit monsieur millan ti et oui et bien
le concurrent alésia a donc gagné cette
épreuve et il devait y avoir à nouveau
deux nouveaux points qui vont s'inscrire
au score tandis que l'indien les indiens
de services avec les algériens jeunes
sur le tableau de marquage à la grande
joie des soixante quinze mille
spectateurs qui sont là on va redoubler
parce qu'il n'y aurait plus en plus 4 à
0 pour la ville de lens va dire que le
jockey d'alès monsieur elio tir est
extraordinaire dans les dernières
battues il aurait fallu toute la verve
et l'enthousiasmé de notre ami d'andy
trône pour décrire ça comme les derniers
100 mètres entre le pavillon et le
pesage de longchamp un bilan apparaît
jeu comme ça mais pour le suivant si
entend pas bien parce que notre ami lyon
n'aime pas la voiture et n'aime pas
beaucoup les tapis roulants et pourtant
ce jeu du péage va rappeler la
circulation et va se passer comme aller
le voir car je vais demander maintenant
caméra de jean crenn et de georges garié
de venir sur l'autre au tapis roulant va
se passer sur deux tapis roulant
parallèle ce qui est évidemment tout à
fait nouveau dans intervilles et bien
sûr pour se rendre à perrache sur des
tapis roulants s'abonner voilà qui a de
quoi décourager tous les conducteurs de
france et de navarre
mais il est encore plus pour décourager
les quatre concurrents d'alès et
d'avignon qui vont devoir payer le péage
en marchant sur un tapis roulant
s'abonner et de plus les pieds encerclé
par les chandra
de leur propre voiture il y a six
courses successives les deux premières
se dérouleront avec deux chambres à air
autour des pieds les 2e séries avec
trois chambres à air et la troisième
série avec quatre chambres à air le
premier arrivé dans chaque course au
péage a le droit de mettre la pièce dans
la corbeille marques de poids mais le
deuxième doit finir la course
sinon il ne marquera alors que s'il
finit dans les 45 secondes
il marque un toit et c'est facile à
comprendre qu'il est bon est obligatoire
et salutaire de terminer car les deux
points de ce jeu iront finalement à
l'équipe qui à l'issue des six courses
aura totalisé le plus de points noirs
qui aiment passer devant les caméras on
a des marathoniens envoyé est bien en ce
qui concerne l'équipe d'alès dans un
enclos pas mais sans quoi y ait de
bureaux et mis à l'eau en soudure et
georges jean clottes 30 en métal aux
soudeurs pour l'équipe de dominion
robert del employé municipal et jean
paul pelras maître nageur bien là j'ai
l'impression qu'ils étaient maîtres
nageurs s'en servir alors au départ de
la première course avec deux chambres à
air et bien ce qui va réussir à mettre
la pièce de premiers repérages
attention messieurs dans la soirée c'est
à long terme et à gauche de votre écran
c'est parti
et ce n'est pas que l'homme et ce n'est
pas terminé comme ce sens
la pièce la pièce y avait là plus que
tomber la première j'ai besoin qu'on
peut le confirmer une pièce qui est
tombé à côté du péage c'est important
quelle est la pièce qu'est tombée la
première monsieur bayrou il faut bien
que le dire parce qu'il ya eu une petite
confusion
alors quelle est la pièce qu'est tombée
la première répondez-nous non on vous
entend pas monsieur de là bas cela il
faudrait que quelqu'un la gentillesse
quand même de le crise entre les deux
alliés
[Applaudissements]
sa mission de les alimenter
l'état
ce défaut dans cette ambiance il
faudrait quand même de ceux qui
s'occupent de ce jeu et la gentillesse
de nous donner des renseignements entre
man que par des gestes de sémaphore à
lacets dans les premiers mais la pièce
qu'est tombée la première dedans c'est
la pièce j'ai avec lui
la pièce de l'ess a démonté sans but et
que c'était la pièce de lillian t de
tiger
deuxième départ étant donné que les
tapis roulants ne sont pas
rigoureusement les mêmes nous avons et
les voiliers à cirer les mêmes chances
aux deux équipes
alors maintenant aller c'est à gauche et
avignon andrade attention c'est parti
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
deuxième pièce mais l'autre le
concurrent arrivé en droite
obligatoirement terminer en 45 secondes
sinon on ne marquera pas de points qui
peuvent être précieux regardez comme il
a du mal à atteindre de pillage c'est
vraiment un parcours difficile pour lui
c'est un chauffeur qui a des difficultés
avec la stabilité de sa voiture et bien
les choses vont se gâter maintenant
parce que nous arrivons à la deuxième
série de courses alors qu'à l'aise pour
l'instant à 4 points sur mon petit
décompte et avignon deux points c'est
maintenant c'est la course avec trois
chambres à air
je vous rappelle pas important de
règlement il faut finir la course dans
les 45 secondes au moins marquée à pois
bien sûr de poids dont on arrive le
premier attention messieurs proches
embraer toujours le ph c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
sans un changement salué hier il ne
serait pas aujourd'hui tiennent et voilà
le candidat d'avignon qui arrive quand
même
dans les 45 secondes de sorte qu'à
l'issue de la troisième course dans 6.3
on inversait les secteurs je demande aux
techniciens du savon noir et de la crème
renversée de bien vouloir vérifier
on a quand même le temps dans nos
intervilles de vérifier l'état des tapis
roulants qui me paraissent quand même
par la chaleur suffocante être quand
même un peu moins glissant cuillère
alors s'il vous plaît messieurs voulez
vous rechargez les tapis et balance
comme un bien si vous avez demandé à
notre ami monsieur le député maire et à
son adjoint ainsi qu aux autres ce qu'il
pense un petit peu de cette ambiance et
de la chaleur qui règne à l'aise alors
monsieur roucaute vous d'abord alès
passe pas mal pour le moment change
passe très bien je vois que les
représentants dans notre ville se
défendre dignement et font honneur à la
capitale des cévennes
elles sont pas du tout été mené par les
seuls à avoir l'habitude
monsieur millions qui de toute façon on
garde l'espoir un hangar devant son nom
dans l'espoir mais le sourire je me
disais tout à l'heure
quand danic mais en admettant que nous
partions nous garderions le même sourire
savez même garder notre vin ce qui
montre que la chaleur pour notre part et
monsieur collum sava oui vous savez que
monsieur colomb est l'homme qui a
découvert
mireille mathieu elle avait son chemin
avignon aussi mais vous beaucoup moins
de mireille mathieu qu'avignon place
quand même je suis bien content que
qu'avignon recueilli nature vos
interviews dignement et je pense que
notre équipe ici ce terrain reprendra
également avignon de la même façon la
balle est bien maintenant je crois qu'on
est prêt pour la troisième course avec
trois chambres à air
je rappelle le score à la moitié puisque
nous en étions à la mi temps 6 points
seulement pour alès 3 points pour
avignon c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
san paro 503 des conducteurs de voitures
ce sont des gardiens de l'équipe
internationale de football iphone c'est
plongeant 8.4 est bien à moins d'un
renversement qui me paraît maintenant
probable je crois que les deux points de
ce jeu vont concrétiser encore davantage
de thales qui devient très inquiétant
dans cette interview je les bats marché
un grand pas maintenant nos amis d'alès
pour la finale 22 septembre
actuellement et bien nous en sommes à la
dernière série avec 4 changerait
attention messieurs vous êtes prêt levé
la main droite et jure
bon bah ils veulent pas juré ils ont
bien raison d'ailleurs ils ont d'autres
soucis que de jurés en ce moment ils ont
celui de ce te rester sur leurs deux
jambes et ça n'est pas facile croyez moi
c'est une partie seulement par paresse
c'est mal parti pour avignon aussi les
deux sont à terre mais il y en a même un
qui revient en arrière
il en rire de moi l'un des chanteurs
demain et le chambre à air de moi et ne
changèrent de moi il y à une chute
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a l'air
épuisé les mois qu'il se soit légèrement
blessé ce serait quand même dommage
dans ce cas nous lui donnerons sans
hésitation les deux points de ce jeu
qu'est ce qu'il a pu se faire
pourtant il était en pleine forme il a
plongé la doire il doit y en a beaucoup
plus de peur que de mal
alors état étant donné ces six repensant
je crois que le public ici ne nous en
voudra pas malgré qu'il ait perdu une
chambre en route de donner ces deux
points à avignon vous êtes d'accord
[Applaudissements]
d'accord comme centres ouverts parce
qu'ils sont d'accord avec çà marche on
n'entend pas ceux qui sont pas d'accord
alors dernier dernière épreuve qui à mon
avis ne peut pas modifier le score final
qui est actuellement maintenant de 10 ha
à 6 ça ne peut plus modifié mais pour le
plaisir et pour l'honneur
voici la dernière des courses avec 420 m
attention messieurs allez sa gauche
avignon à droite le péage au milieu les
tapis roulant sous vos pieds les jambes
rien autour de vous et la pièce dans les
marque-pages croit tout avare dire il
oublié si ce n'est de vous donner le
départ s'est fait partie
[Applaudissements]
chez toi
chut chut toute rechute on se trouve est
en train de faire une partie de bridge
ya au mas de chute l'a terminée avignon
a fini le premier ce qui fait que à bord
des comptes
et bien malgré ce retour en force des
deux dernières séries avignon en ayant
gagné que deux courses sur six es1 es4
c'est quand même un récit gang sept
coureurs
dans ce milieu qui pourrait peut-être ou
appeler au secours parce que regarder au
dessus de nos têtes
voulez-vous les caméras montées de
quelques étages et nous allons inscrire
maintenant rue mazelle six points
d'impôts alès
[Applaudissements]
maintenant nous allons simone et
ensemble parler d'une circulation
restent élevés pour ça d'ailleurs une
circulation comme seul on peut en voir
dans interview au départ de ce jeu qui
s'appelle le sens interdit
une vache c'est d'ailleurs la vache sens
interdit et de voitures qui sont
composés de trois éléments plus de
police mène les polices men vont avoir
un rôle extrêmement précis à jouer
puisque en effet les cinq voyageurs des
deux voitures ont pour mission d'aller
se heurter de plein front c'est à dire
le devant de leur voiture sur l'école du
sens interdit
c'est à dire sur les cornes de rosita
qui va maintenant faire son entrée dans
l'arène or à chaque fois qu'il y à un
choc que c'est avantageux car l'agent de
la même équipe doit verbaliser et pour
ce faire et bien ces agents ont pour
mission simone et bien d'accrocher un
anneau au porn de la tâche et c'est
seulement à ce moment là après la
collision et après le procès verbal sous
forme d'anneau qu'on peut faire marquer
un poids pour l'équipe ce jeu dure six
minutes est déclaré vainqueur à l'issue
de ces six minutes bien entendu l'équipe
qui a eu le plus de collisions et le
plus de procès mer pour attention on va
faire sortir
zita et messieurs à partir de là sens
interdit à volonté c'est parti il ya
bien eu dans l'interview 15 à 60
interdit à volonté rosita se fait un peu
attendre ce fait un peu désirer elle
doit être en train de se faire maquiller
une vache qui se fait maquiller tout à
l'heure ça sera peut-être les joueurs
qui auront les yeux maquillés et voilà
rosita toubel un peu différente au
spectacle mais qui immédiat
marché de plein front l'équipe fanion se
voient pénalisés vers l'asie donc un peu
pour adoption
aussi toute la spéciale
voici la collusion envisager maintenant
que le petit agente à l'aise tout il
faut que le petit jardin les scouts du
commun
je voudrais pas par exemple
notre ami qui était à cheval sur l'étang
de marque hp comme on est loin de la
sardaigne en sicile l1
la commission doit d'abord à bignan 3
pour avignon matin s'y attendait les
provinces et tous ses mythes bientôt
voilà un jeu qui va très bien pour vous
je n'ai pas regardé deux médiateurs
seulement pas le temps qui reste à
écouler et j'aimerais que quelqu'un
vienne nous l'indiqué un chronométreur
non pas par pur appât renseigner nous a
lu sur la durée du jeu je sais pas si le
deuxième procès verbal de d'alès a été
marqué je crois qu'on
attendez le vol à la 3 3 ou 3 2 il faut
dire que les agents là ils ont ils ont
forte à fond en tord avignon alors ça va
être une quatrième collision n'attendait
ans nathan lane on en attend la nouvelle
union
ah non non pas du quatrième monsieur
biblique et à vous mettez les bouchées
doubles la 24e voilà le quatrième il
reste trois minutes exactement dans ce
jeu est actuellement vidéo sinon même
pas et bien émis en 4-4-2 tous les yeux
de toute façon je ne sais pas exactement
mais on a nos vitres quatre à al harra
n'est séparé la vitre à monsieur d'un
ambitieux on peut dire que ce sont les
agentes heures
[Applaudissements]
la pelle à neige c'est au pilori au
dollar est de l'agent
5 l union de toute façon les séquelles
des reportages pour avignon contre
l'excellent qu'il est quand même des
d'un certain sang-froid
c'est sympathique agent d'al est
ailleurs oh et celui d'avignon également
à vous savez qu'ils sont formidables
alors un client vient de marquer six
après sentiment que les agents
manifestation n'aurait leur dos ils
craignent absolument à alès y retourne
bravement six courts alignant ce doit
être le cinquième je pense pas la
tendance à 6 à 4 et voici deux se
tiennent maintenant pour avignon
tu sais moi maintenant dit-il en tentant
une nouvelle tactique matin les
partenaires de 7 à d'enfourcher la vache
par ses arrières
il reste maintenant une limite 30
et quel est le score exact simone et
qu'est ce c'est à 4 je crois à tendance
bonne en avignon en 1/8 8,8 de 4 ha ha
du côté d'alès j'ai fait un départ des
boucles d'oreilles candidat que je vais
rentrer chez moi
notre agent de l'ess voyez-vous à l'air
de jeter l'épongé pourtant sauvé
ce n'est plus à l'emploi blanc sépia
sens interdit maintenant là c'est
vraiment rentrer chez moi
neuf est mignon mais ce qu'on adore
porter la voiture il est ami
1 ne pas pouvoir vous recevez à 3,5
parce que 9 5 900 s'interdit deux côtés
d'annie ensemble de codes et dares eh
bien monsieur négative et pouvoir
attacher vos ceintures
le boeing
à décoller pour marquer leur seconde
je ne crois pas ma tante et les à
pouvoir monter à laisser un avis un
autre là maintenant
si ce n'est pas si long il l'a pas mais
il n'a pas brillé avignon à ce qui la
met le 10e a lancé en dix ans en
quelques secondes
oui second il habite oui et bien 10
secondes un moment je n'osais discorde
c'était plusieurs procès verbal et là
j'en ai tellement fatigué qui demandent
toujours la rage de raccompagner chez
lui
voilà et maintenant attention au top
c'est bien l'idée est bien ce jeu voit
la victoire d'avignon qui va être saluée
comme il se doit par ce public très
fair-play d'alès outre l'affichage est
rentré qu'ils aient faut dire qu'avec
après que 50 degrés dans cette arène qui
est à une véritable fournaise les
joueurs bout de six minutes sont
absolument extérieur c'est la traversée
du soir est bien 6 à 2 alors que nous
allons attaquer maintenant 28 simone
attaquer toute façon parler parce que
ici tout est pacifique
le 5 juin le ciel qui mesurait très beau
être d'alès soyez pas par ibsa d'avignon
quand même les inscrire merci
mademoiselle ne vous laissez pas
influencer par l'entourage
oui être piéton c'est une aventure et
être piéton c'est une aventure
périlleuse
ce n'est pas si facile nous allons
découvrir maintenant sur un passage
clouté parce que c'est le seul refuge
possible pour les piétons sur un passage
clouté
nous allons retrouver quatre personnages
alors ces quatre personnages que nous
appelons de toute urgence parce que je
dois dire que nous sommes très nombreux
tout
monde voilà ça y est nous avons l'équipe
d'alès ce qui commence c'est l'équipe
d'alès ou d'avignon
alors quatre piétons alors se porter sur
le jeu cas c'est parce que si le dernier
ravissante mais ses admirateurs vont
s'entredéchirer s'ils restent trop
longtemps
il faut certes pas le tenter alors s'il
vous plaît sur le passage clottey je
voudrais les quatre personnages qui sont
respectivement un chauffeur de taxi un
homme grenouille un monsieur le curé est
une demoiselle en jean blanc eh bien ces
quatre piétons vont être pourvus chacun
d'un parapluie retourner contenant des
ballons dans chaque parapluie 10 ballons
nos piétons vont devoir sauter en
cadence car un cinquième coéquipier va
tirer sous leurs pieds
35 m de toile de jute
il s'agit donc de sauter piano mesure
est de sauver les ballons qui sont dans
les parapluies
alors attention messieurs ayez beaucoup
d'ensembles je vous signale qu'à
vous partez avec 4 x 10 ballons c'est à
dire 40 ballons enfin si jamais il ya
quelque chose de toute façon nous avons
des arbitres lac et nous dirons ce qui
se passe n'est ce pas monsieur bayrou
alors on part en principe avec 40
maintenant on comptabilisera à l'arrivée
les ballons qui seront sauvés et je vous
signale que pour tous ballons perdus il
y à une pénalisation de 5 secondes par
équipes
c'est donc évidemment l'équipe qui aura
fait le meilleur temps pour ses 35
mètres de tissu qui l'emportera alors je
crois que cette fois tout est ok vous
voyez les silhouettes bizarre c'est
avignon au départ alors non piétons sont
prêts le cinquième coéquipier on a le
goût des uniformes aujourd'hui est prêt
aussi à tirer
voilà attirer les 35 mètres de tissus
durée limite de ce jeu deux minutes de 3
de hausse c'est parti lescure est ce
normal pauvre départ
la mesure a perdu tous ses candidats en
tout cas le chauffeur de taxi les a tous
gardé leur grenier gourmand et le doyen
ça s'passe parole elle envoyait avec
quelques l ensemble voyez-vous qu'on se
soulève
s'il vous plaît les assistants vous
laisser les ballons pour empêcher les
comptabilisés à la fin du jeu merci
merci
eh bien vous voyez sur l'écran le
chronométrage de ce jeu je vous rappelle
qu'on va compter les noms et que tous
les ballons perdus
cinq secondes chaque fois ajouté autant
abadie taux à 10 ans c'est pas mal et
ancien terril et ça s'est terminé à 48
secondes alors 48 secondes ça fait très
important je sais pas il faudra un petit
papier un petit rayon 48 secondes et on
va compter les ballons alors s'il vous
plaît monsieur pairraud qui est venu
tout exprès de saint gaudens parce
qu'avec intervilles on se fait des amis
partout elle sur robert byron wien être
à l'école combien de ballons monsieur
pairraud 15 15 ballons 13 13 13 ballons
perdus c'est les ballons perdus que vous
avez signalé dans sauvés on attendait
tout savoir
j'en ai gardé stress de son v alors je
pense qu'elle avait 40 au début
alors si c'est ça il y en avait donc 27
de perdus ou le lob sur le code vous
avez besoin d'un petit calepin alors 27
ballons perdus avec 5 secondes par balle
en maudit dont il faut faire des
mathématiques nouvelle ça va franchement
vous êtes formidables heureusement que
je vous ai à mes côtés tenez 135 sur
allons avec 48 secondes
on fait des éditions vous voulez
convertir tout ça chez vous tandis qu'on
fait
je pense qu à intervilles voyez vous on
a pas de secret et on est obligé de
faire ménage devant vous alors je
rappelle que 48 secondes +135 secondes
et compte de monsieur roux peuple
monsieur médias ont dit vous lui faites
confiance au liban pour les fêtes pour
faire sa télé les taux d'avignon allez
messieurs au lit parapluie s'il vous
plaît allez on monte attention 3 2 un
top on fait partie le condo
[Applaudissements]
un peu déplorable de mercure et vole un
peu avant mais ça n'a pas l'air gêné
jusqu'à
ta cure et contestataire d'ailleurs ils
étaient bouclés 1
[Applaudissements]
là
celle qui vient de chuter en insultes et
jamais une femme qui tombe toute façon
aller perdu tous ses ballons
je vous rappelle qu'elle a eu 13 de ce
retour abîmé en tout à l'heure alors on
va tout de suite savoir
il me semble qu'à l'aise balle au je ne
sais pas où il va un peu plus vite ils
en firent moins 48 secondes
ouais quarante six voiliers 46 secondes
c'est le le chronométrage indiqué sur
l'écran à la rencontre ce qui reste je
crois que ce soit prête pas la peine de
te feront leur avis doit vous donner
résultat ces vols est le ballon il reste
neuf ballons neuf ballons il en restait
13 tout à l'heure pour avignon et bien
malgré la différence je crois que les
deux bois vont revenir à avignon allez
soyez de quoi une fois monsieur willy
antilles qui veut dit l'air faussement
navré je le regrette pour alès
voulez-vous être sincère s'il vous plaît
vous êtes ravi conseil d'opel dans les
dites le que vous êtes ravi je suis ravi
bien sûr nous allons continuer dans ce
thème de la circulation alors que les
inscrivant quatre points pour avignon 6
points pour le loyer qu'il y a
faut jamais vendre la peau de l'ours et
qu'un peu plus de la moitié des jeux et
bien avignon fait un retour très
spectaculaire d'ailleurs c'est une
équipe aguerrie
impossible n'est pas français je sans
frontières dieu sait si vos équipiers
connaissent un petit peu la musique mais
la musique il faut le reconnaître
jusqu'au bout surtout lorsqu'il s'agit
avec l'autorisation de monsieur gillioz
ti de toute la municipalité de sa ville
d'avoir déplacé exceptionnellement oui
oui le pont d'avignon dans les arènes
d'alès regarder mais un pont d'avignon
ont démonté et qui fait vis-à-vis 1 sont
plus modestes rival le pont d'alès et
bien pour l'instant comme vous pouvez le
voir ils sont au sol mais les
constructeurs n'attendent qu'un signe
pour se mettre au travail
malheureusement dans leur s compte
cheetah je ne sais pas celle qui va
rentrer joyeuse vaches camarguaise va
peut-être troubler le chantier de
construction et pourtant il faut
absolument édifié ses deux ponts car
c'est seulement après que commencera
véritablement le jeu puisqu'il faudra
faire passer conchita au dollar est plus
de fois possible sous son propre peau la
victoire ira à l'équipe sous le pont de
laquelle la vache camarguaise aura le
plus de fois passé attention la présence
d'un équipier au sommet du pont
lorsqu'il est construit est absolument
obligatoire pour en vérifier la solidité
je vais demander à l'oméga scop est prêt
à démarrer je dure six minutes il y a
cinq joueurs pour chaque équipe
enough éléments de pont et vous allez
voir il va y avoir du sport attention
chronomètre six minutes parti lâchée de
le reste consiste à ont commencé les
collègues simone rabassa c'est celui de
leurs skis conchita
c'est suzanne cézanne ou germaine j'ai
pu alors voilà le pont d'avignon et on
s'y connaît un bon début en général
toute forme il ya dix ans j'avais fini
mon avis une cravate est fini il est
toujours en construction
nous n'avons pas râler la légende ni
l'histoire le pont d'avignon se
construit par élément neuf éléments
envoyés léger et il faut bien sûr pour
le terminer mettre la clé de voûte est
pour l'instant la vache qui d'ailleurs
est autre qu un taureau me signale temps
ça n'est donc pas germaine mais elle
doit être félix et bien félix de
taureaux de bayonne est bien pour
l'instant notre ami félix de thor est un
spectateur attentif n'est plus alors il
s'agit de faire passer voilà est un peu
pour aller
maintenant le plan daleth et mais ça ne
compte pas car le candidat n'était pas
au sommet donc le premier passage ne
compte pas il faut obligatoirement un
équipier au sommet du port de 50
c'est dommage pour aller semer le
premier passage ne comptait pas pour
l'instant avignon nancy n'en finit pas
de ne pas finir
[Applaudissements]
au premier passage dans l'essai bon
interviendrait pas de construire les
arts l'hôtel d'avignon qui sont en
déplacement devenue le passage sur le
pont et la foule hurle sa joie
alors comment déjà une minute porte et
que miro qu'un passage sur les ponts
pour laisser l'entraînement c'est que
troisième passage sous le pont dans
l'est est nu troubler la fête et a
complètement réduit pour l'instant à 0
les espoirs d'avignon puisque le qu'on
n'est même pas construit nous en sommes
à trois passages trois passages
blu ray le sort d'élise
[Applaudissements]
peu de minutes 86e
un peu plus tard
corbett mois décourager les
constructeurs à lyon on était bien là
les restaure dario d'alexis d'el harrach
qui relève dans le vert tombé japon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alain
quelque chose qui me semble compromis
car
admettant cependant tout à fait à moitié
du jeu encore te lis pas sans permis car
dans ce jeudi avec la répétition des
renversement spectaculaire des
renversements de pau
comportant des départs il y n'y avait
pas le concurrent voiliers qui est
perché impassiblement sur l'épaule à la
cigale en le concurrent au sommaire des
excédents
ce n'est pas fini
en revanche elle est ce que félix
bassereau manifester pour faire son
cinquième passage sur le panda l'est
oui je veux dire que l'on doit ce
passage peu plus au magnifique raster de
metz qui s'est laissé porter l'idéal
manta police elle ne porte pas les
portes d'avignon
car c'est à dire que le rasta là et ça
le génie à la flotte doit passer rixos
où sont tombés dame également félix sous
le pont d'avignon ce qui fait qu'à
chaque fois les pauvres constructeur qui
pourtant ne se décourage pas et qu'on
devrait applaudir valeurs les
constructeurs l'allemand attendu
alesina il nous reste encore une minute
gaz on ne sait jamais oui
si on m'annonce par la cour
maintenant le fait passer en appartement
de tenir la rage par là que monsieur un
postulat positions vis de cet amant en
forme de ce pont vous n'aurez pas
beaucoup de visiteurs et amis gâtés
cette année dans ses ventes avec les
attentions sur le plan les normes à
passer de fou
la lutte à dire que le constructeur sans
cervelle mois à dix longueurs quelques
jours n'est pas reconstruire un coup et
pourtant nous étions bien partis pour
penser que c'est tellement la vidéo plus
célèbre des deux seniors
je prend finalement la tradition et
l'histoire sont bien respectés que dans
le viseur des big c jeu mais pour vous
un intérêt bien compris il eût mieux
valu que ça ne soit pas respectée comme
ça pendant près de 4 minutes 41 de
chronomètre eh bien on va peut-être
quand même voir le pont d'avignon
construire qui sera quand même à
l'événement dans ce jeu maintenant
qu'est-ce que tu n'en as pas cillé
lorsque ce petit tard le cas bien
téméraire et bien d'intrépides d'un drap
et là haut
alors que la vache vous exactement
l'état vient de passer pour la septième
fois sous le pont d'alès et a voulu
ignorer maintenant qu'il est construit
le pont d'avignon
alors qu'avignon matteau de brécy quand
même de le faire passer de deux fois ne
serait ce que pour l'honneur alors
mademoiselle monsieur félix voulait pas
aller visiter le panda vie
oui non peut-être oui alors le vaisseau
ne serait pas le monde il serait très
fade in usa
[Applaudissements]
deuxième bon sens l'avignon
au 10ème passage dans wind on ira ira
pas aucune bosse bretonne s'intitule
attention troisième passation avignon à
la la c'est dommage et dix entrées un
peu tard mais faut dire qu'elle est ya
mis du sien pour empêcher avions compris
et ils ont bien joué leur jeu
il ne reste plus que 6 45 secondes
attention ceci ce sont les derniers
temps et maintenant rien on va demander
à la foule d'applaudir et quand la vie
les deux équipes alors que l'autopartage
d'indiquer je lis vérité parce que pour
l'instant il est toujours à la marque
précédent
le store de 8 points pour alès et 4.824
m'a dit mon bureau quand il paraît que
l'une des spécialités alésienne ce sont
les tripes c'est de manger des tripes
qui donne un tel tennis à vos
concurrents aujourd'hui à ben vous voyez
que les représentants de la ville d'alès
ont vraiment de la tripe c'est vrai
qu'il aime mais annonce sur le terrain
et qu'il y avait une petite
rétrospective et pour ceux que la
nostalgie du passé
on va pouvoir constater que la
circulation même au grand siècle et que
c'était pas si facile que ça nous allons
aussi assisté en effet au départ d'une
marquise pour la cour de versailles dans
sa chaise à porteurs c'est une chaise à
porteurs qui avec ses barreaux n'est pas
sans rappeler l'ancêtre un peu raffiné
du panier à salade
notre marquise dans sa chaise à porteurs
en porte des cadeaux à l'intention de sa
majesté le roi des cadeaux qui sont
figurés par des ballons mais et la salle
un fort du voyage aux déplorables et
adhérons aux intempéries les pluies les
vents vont s'ajouter les attaques d'une
marquise adverse
jalouse qui armé d'un jet d'eau vacher
ne les voyageurs et va essayer soit de
disperser soit de détériorer les cadeaux
qui sont à l'intérieur de la chaise à
porteur alors but de chaque équipe est
bien faire le voyage le plus vite
possible et sauver le maximum de ballons
cadeau à l'arrivée on comptera les
ballons qui seront restés chaque ballon
représentera une seconde et ses seconds
seront déduites du trajet du temps total
mis à effectuer le voyage
alors attention quatre trajets ou si
vous préférez deux allers et retours les
laquais de la comtesse son d'alès le
jette entre les mains naturellement de
la marquise d'avignon qui se tient toute
prête à intervenir
et attention le trio va prendre la route
pour une durée limite de deux minutes
attention droit 2-1 top 50
premier handicap voyez-vous la marquise
d'alès a laissé éclater quelques ballons
la peau tandis que c'est porter son tube
ont aspergé un point
cette licence se risquer sur les cadres
d'un chemin tout blanc de deux bouées
mais qui ne sont plus du tout des bouées
de sauvetage alors attention coûte que
pour nico gravir la montée ces premiers
trajets un genou signal olala que cette
porte est malaisé malaisé p1000 on opère
déjà très chaud
comment ça mais pas
cette coopérative mais très loin de
porter plainte
je ne peux plus la partie
je vois plus rien
alès débloquer la partie de plus au vu
de ce mauvais pas tandis que da
l'autre pouces et naturellement la
marquise
consciencieusement les porter et
également la voyageuse petit mois c'est
l'âge classique on sait que la chaise à
porteurs j'ai l'impression qu'elle va
s'ouvrir et l'a vu perdre aux marquises
restez avec nous marquise cramponnez
vous savez les goûts
cette époque là c'est une véritable
aventure du x 10 ports dit manquer la
marque ici parce qu'il est désolé
monsieur le maire mais elle a pris un
fou rire vous avez inextinguible malgré
le génome elle est là la perruque aux
côtés
mieux elle était pâle handicap de ton
pâté et pour l'instant elle est pourtant
[Applaudissements]
ces gens tirer de ce pas difficile
allez messieurs d'alès allez-y la
descente ça va toujours mieux à me
donner l'effet qu'un trajet je vous
rappellerai messieurs vous avez le
trajet inverse
plus un autre aller retour le demande de
minutes
et comme il ya déjà j'ai l'impression
que la plus pure on a vu un temps fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
on a passé deux nuits on a recommencé à
compter on en est à 18 ce grand parc
façon messieurs revenez d'où vous êtes
parti soyeuse héroïque
on rajouter minutes royal dont nous
avons parlé de deux minutes au début on
va allez messieurs vous avez encore
quelques secondes en est on pour
terminer en tranches et or voyez vous il
faut être dévoué à sa marquise mais ils
sont dévoués geste allemand lors de
laquelle ans jusqu'à la mort par
asphyxie son jet d'eau tandis que la
marquise moyenne on soigne son honneur
elle a perdu sa férule à la paire de les
cadeaux pour sa majesté allez messieurs
[Applaudissements]
heureusement qu'on a touché un menteur
parce que j'ai l'impression que celle ci
c'est laminé en trois minutes pile à
tabriz et or est obligé simone de
modifier légèrement règlement il faudra
quand même tenir compte du temps mis par
les deux équipes étant décrit l on avec
la violence du gène et l'ardeur avec
laquelle la marquise d'avignon et
pendant celle d'alès maintenant aoc deux
équipiers ont un mal un peu quand un mal
fou même une impossibilité notoire de
terminaux comme il est donc en trois
minutes encore le nom de valeurs chez
perrault et tous se sont aussi plaints
2,4
[Applaudissements]
et seul
16 secondes à enlever les trois minutes
pour un trajet aller retour à part sur
trois minutes vous n'arrêtez le
chronomètre qu'à trois minutes puisque
le temps réalisé par l'équipe de
résister 2-3 minutes tout rond
eh bien il faut reconnaître que la
marquise d'alès est sorti avec un grand
enthousiasme de sa chaise à porteurs
pour qu un peu meurtri et a sauté
littéralement sur le jet d'eau parce que
maintenant elle attend sa collègue a dit
mme younès avec croyez moi beaucoup
d'agressivité alors les lacs et
d'avignon la marquise de l'union vous
est prêt à relever mais voyez-vous la
marquise et du mans aux doctrines et par
monsieur jurant qui est chef d'equipe
tout est ok vous avez votre nombre de
ballons les cadeaux sont prêts pour le
roi la marquise est prête les lacs est
prêt à affronter tous les périls de la
route
martin tournée vous un petit peu fait un
petit sourire à la caméra qu'on vous
voit martine notre parole notre marquise
d'alès la voilà voyez comme elle est
mignonne sans perruque un de ces petits
cheveux courts tout inondé alors
attention maintenant la vengeance est un
plat qui se mange ou à martin 3 2 1
attention attention
trois deux un top c'est parti la
vengeance est un plat qui se mange
j'ai 28 ans comment
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas si on mettrait bien une
peur aux marchés
[Applaudissements]
la bascule complètement il bascule la
marquise
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est à leur écoute et jusqu'à
maintenant la méthode du pont à
écoutez je ne sais pas si le véhicule
est l'impact de cette façon mettons les
marquises
va pour les marques et ça a l'air de
marcher très fort où c'est le premier un
de la caisse
regardez la carte moss 44 secondes
il a déjà effectué un trajet on retourne
maintenant
il penche la terre il présente son
tricorne au chef de l'arctique est alors
qu'ils se dotent tout moi tant de la
marquise et marées côté elle est très
très bien
elle est même temps d'exploiter cet
ancien les timorés arcand m
martin ne manquent pas gros plan on
bascule toujours n'achète à porter
mais on avait confiance on avait
confiance
non
on s'y prendra-t-il on s'étreint hommes
s'embrassent nous allons demander à la
toutes les personnes qui sont dans la
même devoir vouloir vous écartez
monsieur monsieur charest voulait voir
voir l'histoire de byzance de faire un
petit peu là la police parce que
vraiment entre les concurrents et les
curieux ont freiné par leur enthousiasme
au cours de ce jeu on ne sait plus où 6e
un sens d'avignon se dresse à lebon
diagne approuverait plus et sa marquise
ne peut même plus heureux sur la cabine
de camion voulez vous écartez s'il vous
plaît monsieur le capitaine d'avignon
s'il vous plaît voilà ce soir peut faire
le décompte des ballons de toutes façons
je crois que c'est parfaitement inutile
y en a au moins deux cinquantaine ça
serait trop lent monsieur perrault il
est indiscutable
ayant réussi mais il est très aisé d'y
regarder beaucoup plus de ballons
l'équipe d'avignon marx et de bois
aucune discussion ce qui fait 6 à 8 ans
vers l'est et nous voici maintenant
arriver simone à la dernière épreuve
sportive qui va se dérouler en deux
manches
monsieur perrault voulez-vous vite gagné
puisque vous nous arrivait de saint
gaudens avec un beau pantalon bleu ciel
un maillot blanc à faire
tous ceux qui font de la réclame pour la
blancheur d'une marque d'une autre volet
vous avant la sortie est de gagner le
milieu de l'arène
pendant que j'explique en quoi va
consister ce dernier match en deux
manches
eh bien ce n'est ni plus ni moins qu'un
toro ball mais un taureau paul qui
comporte que 84 minutes- la première
mi-temps se disputant puisque nous en
sommes actuellement en plein carnaval
d'alès avec 3go state toi avignon et
trois grosses têtes pour alès et bien
sûr que mme arbitre un joyeux compagnons
qui ne s'appelle peut-être pas félix
mais edouard me dis qu'on c'est un
enfant d'edouard est bien trop grosse
tête de chaque côté 4 minutes et la
deuxième mi temps 4 minutes également se
déroulera non plus avec trois joueurs de
chaque côté mais avec 4 mais sans lost
attention monsieur perrault avec coup de
sifflet le ballon par les joueurs
partent et bien entendu edouard
également attention c'est parti
quatre minutes et voilà il s'agit bien
sûr les compris marquer des buts de
martin émue et la vitre commence à jouer
un arbitre qui fut une grosse tête qui
tente de faire du steeplechase on a
complètement mégalo n'y a pas de marquer
pour l'instant il postera de terre
[Applaudissements]
les deux plus grosses fait indéniable
itération avoue le joueur était cette
grosse tête était beaucoup plus au cours
du vote la grosse tête
bon allez il ya deux monstres de terre
s'est pour l'instant ça l'est plus à un
match de football de toro ball c'est un
carnage
regardez la tête alors que là c'est une
tête sans cervelle
et les jordaniens qui étaient toutes de
maintenant je ne suis pas si la majorité
le taureau exactement
là ils sont là
une et c'est une panique générale est
dans la ligne de ce taureau que tout
continue
mais du côté des spectateurs on
neutralise le temps avec bien sûr le
magasin 2 0 feed
le jeu ne compte pas il s'est arrêté à
éliminer pour l'heure était déjà dense
koroma que toronto dans les talents
caire alors considérons que cette
première mi temps se terminera à 4080 et
de l'aller 1 0 c'est bien embêtant alors
on est un peu perdu le chronométreur
aussi le taureau également les joueurs
aussi alors on va essayer de nous y
retrouver
alors on va considérer qu'à partir de la
taille et notre personnel est né le 10
marie le guen stop il reste 2 minutes 30
à jouer deux minutes trente hommes assez
vite le ballon s'il vous plaît aussi
quant à lui
mais pousse à londres
ren d'oublier complètement absurde puis
les bananes mais les joueurs qui
n'oublie également ne le sont pas du
tout débandade pour patins des grosses
têtes blondes ou ses amis
voici à l'est ce qui m'a marqué un but
non
copé
ça n'est marqué un but donne c'est par
cette grosse tête à renty complètement
de tête ou de pied
m
nous avons dix ans
[Applaudissements]
le but le but n'est pas valable monsieur
la veillée vous n'aviez pas votre hôtel
sur vous le but n'est pas valable
vous confondez la première mi temps avec
nos secondes on est en pleine
contestation la remettez votre tête au
moins monsieur sur nos épaules
si l'on peut dire pour continuer à faire
ce jeu s'agit d'avoir la tête sur les
épaules
le taureau qui m'attend s'est bien
amusée se dit si je pouvais rentrer
sauter partir et à la guerre
qu'est ce que c'est drôle d'aller voir
les spectateurs d'un peu plus près
messieurs s'est couché alors de temps en
temps ça ne ferait plaisir et à plus de
trois mètres
c'est plus du tout monde en salle ont
été complètement perdus
pourtant la vache n'est pas rentré
la main
non messieurs ne m'a pas autant marqué
deux buts ça compte aussi 10
[Applaudissements]
cette attaque est encore debout
au dessus est ce que c'était un message
aux confins du rugby et football
il ne reste plus qu'à les dix minutes de
jeu dans un désordre indescriptible de
10 ans cet habitant
[Applaudissements]
monsieur votre tête sur vos épaules de
répondre à tuer comme ça ne viendra
concrétiser aucun débit de marquer car
ne n'est pas du tout dans l'accueil
correct et réglementaires
du toro-ball avec des grosses têtes
noires édictée depuis le 11 mars 1927
c'est bien connu
et même si c'est pas la bonne date et
six appareils
eh bien ça sera depuis le hall où une
personne 73
il n'en reste plus que trois noms a
montré de maître puisqu'il n'y a plus de
promettre qui marche à la télévision
française depuis une bonne dizaine de
minutes
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il ira à bulle je prends ma
petite simone que tout va se concrétiser
dans le 2e 2e mi temps
[Applaudissements]
personne otanesque aussi
parce qu'il tenait
[Musique]
aussi bonne garde
maintenant l'autre les vibrations
non
la note avait pas droit attention
mi-temps qui se ferait sur un but à zéro
pour adecco
[Applaudissements]
rentriez le taureau le taureau vous en
sortir et un autre pour la deuxième mi
temps un peu moins fantaisiste un peu
plus soir de ballons vont rentrer le
torrent vous sortez les têtes vous
faites un peu le ménage et simone
garnier et bien je crois qu'il faut
maintenant avoir nous aussi notre tête
sur les épaules pour savoir où nous en
sommes alors que la deuxième mi-temps va
commencer avec quatre joueurs sans
grosse tête avec le même ballon avec un
autre toro avec un autre arbitre parce
que je crois que tu arbitres et
complètement disparu avant leur venue
est un joueur supplémentaire
un joueur supplémentaire dont nous avons
abordé sera bien dans le béton dans les
coeurs votre flottement ici qu'il ya
actuellement le score de 8.6 pour enfin
leur d'alès que si avignon remporte ce
jeu de toro ball et c'est bien possible
parce qu'à la mi-temps avignon même
parfois 0
et bien notre bon à lui par tour
j'ai gueulé ça risque d'être quand même
très chaud au moment du jeu des
questions à ces deux affiches on s'est
tous inscrits en quatre minutes 4
minutes
elles auront fait partie le prenons la
vache est sorti et choqué
achat
attention
pour la vache est sorti on peut partir
le chronomètre merci pour votre
information les jeunes le top top 10 pas
s'il vous plaît pas trop nos locaux
n'est plus digne et plus de démocratie
et de ses frères et ses condamnations
simone plaira billon a été demi
finaliste de la coupe de france cette
année donc c'est une équipe de football
enfin cette ville où le football a
maintenant ses lettres de noblesse et à
l'espèce de grandes capitales du
football et ares a longtemps joué en
première division et qui dégage de tout
ça va permettre à ce toro ball de
dispute sa 10e en trop mais pour
l'instant eh bien nous en sommes à mi
temps ça va je ne sais pas
je vois
[Applaudissements]
mais parmi les marais arrêté avec deux
secondes avant 6 ans à mardi en
transférant paris-bercy et bien que
lesté beaucoup voyaient et vit d'abord
il se passe une opel qui portèrent au
milieu par elle la vache passe également
sous les buts mais de toute façon et le
droit de rentrer les pécaris cette plage
pour l'instant fait un petit brin de
conduite effectivement aller au courant
pas de but marqué je vous signale que
géographiquement nous avons la même
disposition côte est américaine
[Applaudissements]
mais il a marqué à la main aux à la main
tandis que les plus cool
après son raté le but de l'os de google
c'est trop
[Applaudissements]
la violence est par terre attendent si
on veut dire que
est ce monsieur mais là dedans car il a
été marqué à la main le sujet
[Applaudissements]
neutralisent le chronomètre et c'est
dans la peine de laisser filer étant
donné pour l'instant le genou et rob
neutraliser il n'y a plus des bulles il
n'y a plus de bus pour alez qui doivent
reconstruire
tandis qu évidemment avignon pendant ce
temps et c2 de garder le ballon mais de
toute façon ce n est pas ma spécialité
si l arbitre dans de telles situations
au lieu d'être cachés derrière le talent
terre vous feriez bien droit d'une
décision mais cela dit il est caché
derrière le talent caire alors il se dit
on ne traduisent de jeu ont fait sortir
le torrent et on va remettre le but du
goût n'est plus doivent rester debout
allez on va essayer de reconstruire
fallait mieux aborder non je crois de
toute façon
non ça ne peut pas porter le premier big
ben à la bhl pour alès 1 but partout but
partout
[Applaudissements]
aux analyses de jeu
papa jamie avait des goûts dire pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
elle est pas bon et
y'a pourquoi il est pas bon chemin
pourquoi il est pas bon nous semble et
de travis et le chemin
je veux dire kiev 2 secondes ne me fera
quitter de s'enliser qui fait qu'elles
réparent était un leurre et le pit à
l'aide a été marqué qu'un tel est arrêté
en l'air je disais oui c'est vrai
j'avais neutraliser le jeu qui en ont
gelé annoncé au bureau pourrait en fait
le but ne peut pas être acceptée c'est
pas facile en partie été neutralisée
alors maintenant est ce que le but de
réparer en fin de partie
ressortez edwards ou phoenix bon les
trois dernières minutes les trois
dernières minutes qui on est bien
d'accord tous les deux parce que
j'attends pas toujours ce que vous
circulez
on n'est plus d'accord mais période
lorsqu'il ya plus de 3,2 met il se
retire par audi en a envie attention
[Applaudissements]
mon histoire hahaha
reçus ça n'est pas valable la vache
continue toujours de s'intéresser
beaucoup d'ailleurs aux joies histoire
d'amour et c'est nous
mais ballon à avignon pour le moment
hahaha
alors après la vache hors-jeu cette
belle en cette fois qu'ils sont
conscients des sentiments à dire que les
joueurs d'alès et les jeunes à lyon pour
preuve d'un courage exceptionnel parce
que j'occupe absolument pas du vallon
ignorant complètement là le taureau qui
les charge lavage précharge déb
danger de mort
il est chargé de sens
[Applaudissements]
t
je suis dépens d'une équipe
toujours pour l'instant c'est par
enchantement début david la vache et
dont l utilisation des sept
il faut dire qu'il y avait trois minutes
de jeu est alerte en temps des
prochaines chronomètre pour l'instant un
joueur alésia que tout le monde s'entend
très bien finalement
il ya eu un choc fatal
j'ai conscience non pas pour l'instant
aucun but marqué en cette seconde mi
temps
ce que pour la première un peu en faveur
des vignes ont alors monsieur pas irez
vous nous remettez le balance entre deux
règnes chaque fois s'il vous plaît vous
avez gagné un million
marque un deuxième but dans sept ans
samuel
donc celle
- vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à ce qu'elle est basée là
brady n'ont été demi finaliste de la
coupe de france et qui justifient bien
d'ailleurs sa spécialité en football aïe
aïe aïe désespoir la récente en train de
s'écrouler dans ce jeu est pour
l'instant deux bus dans cette seconde mi
temps en faveur d' avignon alès
alès devrait bien et cg on sait plus
très bien des trois c'est une reste je
dois répondre à l'oeil sur la barre un
oeil sur le ballon
sur le petit écran soit 20 des yeux tout
autour de la tête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quant à la vache elle ne sait plus de
rides les cornes en tout cas elle est
toujours très active et pas du tout
fatigué un nom et j'ai l'impression de
vos joueurs alésien monsieur le maire la
liste laisse un petit peu hâlé l'a1 et
non plus de coeur là en ce moment on va
à chaque fois qu'on va arrêter là parce
que je pense que les trois minutes qui
sont sûrement s'il te plait monsieur
pailleron vous avez 1 minute et le jeu
il reste encore quoi ah ben voilà c'est
merveilleux inapte à prendre mais très
voilà l or on sait plus très bien qu'on
vienne encore 30 secondes qui est ce que
vous êtes d'accord plus que 30 secondes
et on termine je suis d'accord surtout
maintenant que oui c'est 5 à 30 57
30 maintenant là quelque chose comme ma
seconde mais je crois que ça ne va rien
changer le jeu parce que monsieur roux
compte
voyez-vous les alésiens oh oh oh oh oh
est-ce que l'union non non en tout cas à
l'ess a l'air de se rendre il ferait
signe que tout est terminé
terminer maintenant terminée
[Musique]
jouant bien droit à la pause à la pause
poissions cette vache de rambo
légalement et bien là incontestablement
entre la première et la seconde mi temps
c'est avignon qui chaque fois à marquer
davantage donc nous arrivions à ce que
guy prévoyait il ya seulement quelques
secondes messieurs c'est à dire que si
nous nous tournons devant le score nous
allons découvrir que il y a dix huit
points pour alès et maintenant après ce
match de foot 8 points pour avignon
c'est dire messieurs que vous êtes à
égalité et que pour savoir comment va se
dérouler ce jeu culturel que qui va
présenter
il va falloir faire un tirage au sort
vous avez une pièce millions corte où
monsieur méliand t on fait tirage au
sort sur le podium qui je pense oui si
mal et volley ball à ce sport balade à
des scores simone rappelle étrangement
celui de samedi dernier entre evian et
ex
alors il est peut-être bon de rappeler à
nos sympathiques famille monsieur le
député maire et monsieur le maire
adjoint que c'est peut-être grâce à ce
jeu des questions qu'ils vont pouvoir
faire plus de dix points c'est à dire le
score d'evian et faire leur rentrée en
finale tout est encore possible mais il
faut jouer serré on joue et serré alors
une pièce du prestige des vignes en dans
la main de monsieur milliers anti
puisque vous êtes l'invité ont choisi
c'est pile ou face
donc on se bat depuis défi le palais le
palais des papes et l'écusson
alors vous choisissez quoi le palais des
papes ou l'écusson millions le côté
avignon palais des papes alors le palais
des papes où je vis et le palais des
papes
donc c'est à lui que reviendra le choix
si c'est effectivement le palais des
papes monsieur alors que choisissez-vous
de commencer
ou d'attendre non je laisse penser à
l'ess voilà eh bien monsieur le député
maire d'alès c'est donc à vous qu'il
appartiendra d'entamer ce jeu culturel
et de nous dire tout de suite avant que
guînes présente vos trois cerveaux vos
trois têtes très bien sélectionnés dans
votre ville j'en suis persuadé combien
de points vous préféré choisir un point
ou deux points vous savez qu'il y aura
aussi un rattrapage sportif
alors monsieur vos potes je choisis deux
points deux points
merci monsieur débuté mais en même temps
je vais demander en les présentant à
notre sympathique équipe des questions
de délais ce qui s' est composé de
monsieur amis au pardon j'aurais dû
quand même effectivement la galanterie
m'avait directement vers vous et les
vôtres profession d'enseignant
enseignante
alors c'est muhlmann professeur de
musique professeur de musique à un
antiquaire antiquaires et j'espère que
nous aurons une question portant sur le
passé monsieur alors l'équipe d'alès que
vous venez de connaître va avoir à
répondre à l'une des quatre questions
qui comporte que comporte ce jeu et les
allées de 10 ans madame monsieur quelle
est la matière qu'ils ont choisi ces
entre la musique l'histoire le
découverte est là et le sport portant
sur le xxème siècle la musique la
musique a dit le professeur de musique
comme de les madmoizelles qui est je
crois la reine
davignon une demoiselle d'honneur l'
enveloppe portant la question sur la
musique
je vous rappelle qu'il y à deux branches
que vous avez trente secondes pour
répondre que si d'aventuré quelqu'un
dans le public
connaissant la réponse souffler je suis
obligé de l'annuler au détriment de
l'équipe interrogé
voilà pourquoi comme chaque samedi et
depuis des années dans ce jeu des
questions et en général tous les publics
de france et de navarre nous font
l'amitié de nous écouter ouais ils me
demandent le plus grand silence
voici la question vous savez que vous
allez avoir le choix entre six réponses
donc par conséquent ça peut vous
terriblement nous aider comme aux jeux
qui s'apprennent du xxème siècle ya
quelques années c'était le même principe
parmi ces six musiciens dont les noms
apparaissent maintenant sur votre écran
louis murray francis poulenc georges
auric erik satie darius milot et
germaine tailleferre il en est un oui
bien sûr mais il en est à puisque il y a
cinq hommes et une femme cinq musiciens
musiciennes il en est un qui ne faisait
pas partie du fameux groupe des six
lequel louis durait francis poulenc
georges auric erik satie darius milhaud
germaine tailleferre 30 secondes chrono
m 2 points en jeu pour alès
c'est le quatrième une seule réponse
le numéro 4 erik satie
vous me dites erik satie après en avoir
délibéré avec madame monsieur
l'antiquaire est restée pour l'instant
est provisoirement hors du débat
eh bien vous avez raison
ont chois monsieur le maire bon choix
deux points deux points bien gagner et
qui peuvent selon notre nouvelle formule
cette année en devenir 4 à 6 ou vous
acceptez que votre tireur essaye de
marquer un penalty face au gardien de
but d'avignon
quand je dis hein ça devrait être je
devrais dire d'eux puisqu'ils y à deux
fois en jeu d'ailleurs simone va nous
parler de ces deux joueurs oui en effet
monsieur le maire vous savez donc
maintenant si vous voulez doublé ces
deux points acquis pas votre équipe
culturel vous pouvez faire confiance à
votre sportif
mais attention puisque la question
double vos points vous devez tirer deux
fois votre joueur devra tirer deux
penaltys et les réussir 1 il a deux
essais qui doivent être réussi à 11
mètres de distance
est-ce que mention attention détail en
demandant s'il ne les réussis pas les
deux points que votre équipe de question
vient de remporter sont perdus c'est un
choix cornélien monsieur le député maire
alors vous les cinq minutes pendant cinq
minutes c'est peut-être un peu trop 5
secondes avec vos réflexions
nous choisissons les deux points
supplémentaires casse ta peau que vous
avez certainement confiance dans votre
buteur et que vous avez beaucoup moins
confiance dans l'état l'ordre du gardien
venu d'avignon est ce qu'on connaît le
nom du buteur
oui oui et bien le gold avignon c'est
claude pascal que sportivement nous
allons applaudi ristic
tir de thales s'est clos de génie ges
alors messieurs attention le plus grand
silence il faut marquer vos de vue
monsieur pour doubler les points un seul
manquait vous ne remplissez pas votre
contrat et les deux points marqués par
l'équipe culturelle s'en vont en fumée
attention grosse espèce monsieur quand
vous voudrez vous vous concentrez et
quand vous voulez magnifique arrêt du
gardien d'avignon par conséquent quel
que soit ce qui va se passer maintenant
les deux bus ne peuvent pas être marqué
le contrat sportif n'étant pas remplies
on applaudit le gardien but d'avions
tels a fait un très bel arrêt est il
utile de tirer le deuxième les deux
points marqués par l'équipe culturelle
dares santé face et vous vous retrouvez
donc comme avant à 8x et maintenant nous
passons à la présentation de l'équipe
culturelle d'avignon composé de gens de
longueuil secrétaire du comité des fêtes
par les plus forts mais professeur
clément commerçants géant de longueuil
secrétaire du comité des fêtes
eh bien je disais dans le public parce
que je pense que nos amis
téléspectateurs l'avaient très bien
entendu et bien simone vous demandez
maintenant mais je me loterie
représentants de la municipalité
d'avignon quel est le choix des poids et
je demanderai après notre équipe le
choix de la matière
alors monsieur millan ti vous avez
entendu mais je crois que vous m'avez
déjà donné là
ans à l'heure confirmées deux points
deux fois ici on jouera y avoir on
échoue alors messieurs quelle est la
matière qui reste entre la musique
n'existant plus bien sûr histoire
l'histoire
merci à ses rivaux autour du micro
messieurs vous avez également 30
secondes pour répondre à cette question
et vous avez comme précédemment
sinon qu'ils vont vous être faire pour
réfléchir pendant 30 secondes et
répondre à la question que voici
l'expression le français moyen fut créé
au cours d'une déclaration faite à la
presse franco britannique auquel de ces
six hommes politiques
doit-on cette célèbre et fameuse
expression je lis les sinon edouard
herriot
raymond poincaré gaston doumergue paul
reynaud paul déroulède et antoine pinay
vous avez trente secondes pour désigner
de ses six grands hommes politiques
celui qui créa l'expression le français
moyen chronomètre deux points en jeu
score actuel 8 partout raymond poincaré
vraiment pré carré raymond poincaré
réunion à troyes pour décider d'une
réponse qui étaient fausses
c'est à la suite des accords
franco-britanniques en 1924 messieurs
qui doit ré riou s'adressant à la presse
franco britannique eut cette expression
le français moyen est celui qui de bonne
foi en politique reste toujours fidèle à
ses convictions
edouard herriot et bien edouard herriot
radical le socialiste est tombé de deux
points le score actuel étant de 6.8 vous
pouvez encore rattraper ces deux points
grâce à votre buteur simone vous
interviewez notre adjoint au maire alors
évidemment je compte sur l'autre buteur
monsieur bussy pour récupérer les deux
points perdus
voilà monsieur bussy va donc tirer
contre le gardien de but d'alès qui
s'appelle henry florès alors messieurs
monsieur quand vous voudrez monsieur
bussy mais vous vous concentrez vous
avez donc je le répète deux penaltys à
11 m détenant aujourd'hui
sont perdus définitivement pour avignon
et par conséquent le score avant les
deux dernières questions et de 8 pour
alès et de 6 pour avignon et maintenant
monsieur milieux dits augmentent en
avignon c'est à vous de décider si vous
prenez deux points ou 1 point pour cette
dernière question puisque c'est
maintenant avignon de subir la ddt
d'avant-dernière priest je choisis
encore une fois deux points et messieurs
d'avignon dans quelle matière puisqu'il
n'a rien vu que de le sport et si on
sait découverte de branche et 30
secondes
sinon comme d'habitude la question
sportive pour laquelle je réclame le
même silence amis spectateurs que pour
les deux précédentes le plus fabuleux
des tarzan jeune louise muller deux fois
champion olympique du 100 m nage libre à
quatre ans d'intervalle a en outre
remporté également la médaille d'or et
le titre olympique du 400 m nage libre
en cinq minutes 4 secondes 2/10 voyez
quelle époque ont nagé moins vite que
maintenant paris en quelle année
attention si lieu de jeux olympiques et
six années apparaît sur l'écran il vous
appartient de dire en quelle année je
lui eus muller a été champion olympique
du 400 m nage libre
s en 1920 à anvers en 1924 à paris en
1928 dans amsterdam en 1932 à los
angelès en 1936 à berlin ou en 1948 à
londres 30 secondes promettre 1924 à
paris
1924 à paris réponse exacte
pour remonter de deux poids est ce que
vous les garder ou est-ce que vous les
transformez en deux points
supplémentaires
toute la question est là monsieur milly
anti alors cette fois vous avez pris
conseil de vaud de vos collègues
nous allons être sportives jusqu'au bout
nous allons tirer les deux penaltys pour
doubler le score
c'est très bien je crois que tout ce que
j apprécie votre attitude rien l'équipe
d'avignon tombe donc eu le coup de poker
qu'il le mènerait de 6 où elle était
précédemment à 10 s'ils réussissent à a
doublé les deux points qui vient d'être
marqué c'est ce qu'elle nous en savoir
deux penaltys à 11 m
et pendant que les tireurs autres
enfants de se préparer
je rappelle que le monsieur qui vient de
répondants l'équipe culturelle d'avignon
aussi brillamment sur l'année 1924 vient
de me confier qu'il a eu de la peine
pour cette question car les il a été
champion de france de natation en quelle
année monsieur karaté et champion de
france 2 qu'elle distance 100 m papillon
dîner d'autres l'ont déjà fait mais
tellement rêvé envoyée il est vraiment
tombé dans les eaux qui lui fallait
[Applaudissements]
maintenant silence pour deux penaltys
gardons les bulles envie flores et bussy
[Applaudissements]
et vous sans tarder et sans espoir
monsieur les six points ne seront pas
transformés liant 8 me en dise avignon
restera définitivement à 6 on peut donc
considérer maintenant deux choses c'est
khales a sûrement gagné ce match sauf
accident mais que ls peut encore être
qualifiée pour la finale
mais pour cela monsieur le député-maire
deux solutions une seule en fait est la
bonne
la première c'est marqué deux fois à la
question et après deux penalties qui
paraît cet après midi très difficile
alors votre décision et nous avons la
prétention de vouloir accéder à la
finale et pour cela il nous faut marquer
les deux points
alors vous n'avez plus le choix c'est
maintenant les sciences et découvertes
qui vous sont proposés sous la forme
d'une question toujours avec six
réponses possibles en seconde écoutez
bien s'ils lancent merci à tous de ses
six satellites a qui vont apparaître sur
votre écran un seul fut lancée par la
france
lequel passe en 1965
ariel 3967 azur 1969
oscar 5970 et hall 1971
easy ce 2971 également attention 30
secondes pour nous dire de ces six
satellites celui des français
chronomètre
tout se joue sur cette question les noms
et les d'actions sous vos yeux je n'ai
pas besoin d'en dire plus
oscar 5 en 1970 dit très fort oscar 5 en
1970 oscar 5 et 1 malheureusement pour
vous êtes un satellite d'un autre pays
c'était écoles en 1971 et bien les deux
points sont perdus par alès qui se
retrouvent également 6 points
mais si les deux pénaltys ont joué alors
on ne sait jamais ça peut évidemment
tout changer alors votre décision
seulement nous tentons les deux points
aux penaltys et bien c'est une grande
déception qui s'est emparée actuellement
des arènes d'alès
car quoi qu'il arrive maintenant hélas
il faut bien dire que quelle que soit la
prouesse du buteur d'alésiens et bien
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'espoir de
voir ni à l'esprit lion au final alors
monsieur génie ges
voilà vous êtes aux prises avec ce
problème deux points au bout de votre
pied et deux pénalités jeu la tête
alors quand vous voulez prenez votre
temps
[Applaudissements]
je crois que maintenant tout le monde va
retomber sur ce dernier shoot que se
joue la victoire d'alex contre avignon
sinon c'est un match nul attention un
petit peu dans le plus grand silence
second penalty car tout comme s'il avait
tout avait été préparé d'avancé parce
que jouer sur un seul tir
et bien les deux équipes font donc match
nul 6 points partout ainsi prend fin
mais j'ai un ami cette interview et ce
contre avignon qui nous a réservé bien
des émotions bien des contestations mais
qui s'est déroulée dans la joie la bonne
humeur et sous le soleil éclatant des
cévennes
nous vous donnons rendez vous pour le
dernier match chez le dernier derby
régional d'intervilles samedi prochain
entre thiers et le mont d'or simone
avant guerre des mots avec des
personnalités réunies sur le podium et
probablement une dernière vedette dans
les arènes au revoir à tous et bien le
mot appartient à ces messieurs il était
déjà de très bons amis au départ ils ont
suivi les jeux passionnément mais je
crois que vous êtes satisfait évidemment
aux deux finales
monsieur rockot dit pointe de regret
quand même un peu de regret de ne pas
aller en finale et très satisfait du
spectacle auquel nous avons assisté
et nous aussi nous sommes très contents
et nous remercions les publics d'alès
n'est ce pas monsieur méliand t qui a
été fantastique qui a bravé les
insolations qu'on veut dire dans ces
arènes et qui a su créer une ambiance
tout à fait bon enfant une ambiance dont
nous nous souviendrons longtemps
merci monsieur rockot merci monsieur
millan ti au revoir à tous et à samedi
c'était intervilles 73 alès avignon une
émission de guy lux coproduction claude
savary et roger laclau collaborateur
artistique cher
j'ai un lâche décorateur je me cherche
l'ingénieur de la vision jean bouchard
jacques durand assisté de jean pierre
perret et peugeot ingenio du chant
michel bienvenu
assisté de bernard rappaz et danny
smagghe sonorisation jacques hayé
assisté de jean valette chef machiniste
que jacques bourges et j'appuie scène
assisté de georges détour roger dumas
jean pierre julien
serge messanges jo gook amati chef
électricien pied crépeau chef de plateau
lui cire palais accessoiristes gérard en
coin j'en peux plus
cadreur gérard espinasse jacques feyder
jean pierre landais hubert faso gérard
bayon gerin thomas assisté de pierre
mairat
la kabbale biskri et jean-jacques du pot
ses effets spéciaux allait mourir chef
de production jean lameloise script
madeleine bordeaux françoise darche
assistant de réalisation mustapha el
ouaer et jean-paul petonnet
[Musique]